Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Ça ne va pas être simple.
(Rires)
Une graine.
(Rit.)
Tout est dans la graine.
Pour moi, la graine, elle a été semée
en Normandie, à la limite
de la Normandie, en Picardie,
dans un petit village
qui s’appelle Fourcigny.
70 habitants.
Mégalopole.
(Rires)
J’y ai des souvenirs d’enfant libre.
Pas de contraintes.
Quand on voulait aller voir nos copains,
on prévenait juste nos parents
et on prenait les vélos.
On n’avait même pas besoin
de prendre la route,
à travers champs, on changeait de village.
Là-bas, vers Beaurepaire,
on avait construit une cabane dans
les arbres, à côté de la mare à Bielle.
On allait y chercher
des œufs de grenouille.
Régulièrement avec les copains,
on faisait le tour du village,
on faisait le tour du pays.
Notre village, c'était notre pays.
Quand on avait envie de croquer une pomme,
on montait dans un arbre
et on croquait une pomme.
On passait notre temps dans les granges,
dans la paille, avec les copains.
On sautait des ballots de paille
jusque par terre.
(Soupire.)
Maman.
Et puis est arrivée
la maladie de mon frère.
Donc il a fallu se rapprocher de la ville
pour être plus proche de l'hôpital.
Alors, ils nous l’ont bien vendue,
la ville.
« Tu vas voir, on va pouvoir aller
au cinéma une fois par semaine. »
« Tu veux jouer au tennis ?
Eh bien, on t’inscrira au tennis. »
« Et puis, il y a la bibliothèque.
La bibliothèque, on pourra y aller
souvent. C’est très intéressant. »
Et donc on est arrivé à la ville : Amiens.
La grande ville.
On est arrivé dans un quartier qui, à
l’époque, s’appelait « le petit Chicago ».
Le petit Chicago, alors...
(Rires)
Le petit Chicago. Bof.
Il a fallu tout réapprendre.
« Dis donc toi, qu’est-ce
que tu fais dans cet arbre ?
Descends de là ! »
« Mais cette prune, tu l’as prise à qui ?
- Je voulais juste manger une prune.
- Descends de là ! »
« On ne marche pas dans les pelouses. »
« Hé ! Cette grange, propriété privée ! »
Il a fallu apprendre
à marcher dans le cadre.
J’avoue que, de temps
en temps, j’en suis sorti.
Mais bon, c’est la vie,
alors on s’y fait, on se fait à tout.
Les copains, oui, le cinéma, super,
la bibliothèque, vraiment pas mal -
plein de belles choses.
Et puis les études.
Alors les études...
Aujourd’hui, je suis jardinier.
À peu de choses près,
j’ai failli rater ma carrière.
J'étais à deux doigts de finir médecin.
(Rires)
Et parallèlement à mes études de médecine,
Je m’occupais des enfants
du quartier à la cantine.
Je leur faisais semer des plantes.
On faisait pousser des fleurs,
on fleurissait l’école.
On avait même fait un petit bout
de potager dans la cour de l’école.
J’avais ramené un petit bout
de mon pays, là, dans la ville.
Mais rapidement je me suis dit que les
études, je n’y trouvais pas mon compte,
il fallait que je mette
les mains dans la terre.
Donc il a fallu vers 91 commencer
à se poser les bonnes questions.
Et j’ai décidé de stopper.
Mais que faire ?
À l’époque,
il y avait encore le service national.
Ça non plus, ça n’était pas trop mon truc.
La question s’est posée :
est-ce que je vais donner une année
de ma vie à la nation pour apprendre
à tuer ceux qui seraient
peut-être mes amis
si je les rencontrais
dans une autre situation ?
Vous imaginez bien la réponse.
Donc j’ai décidé, par honnêteté,
de passer deux années
en tant qu’objecteur de conscience.
Il a fallu trouver une structure
pour accueillir ce parcours-là.
Et c’est là que Maman est revenue encore.
Tous les ans, elle faisait sa sortie
avec sa classe dans les hortillonnages.
« Je pense que
les hortillonnages vont te convenir.
- Ok. »
Rencontre avec le président,
validation du parcours,
et je me retrouve le 3 novembre 1992 sur
le quai de l’association de sauvegarde,
en plein milieu de l’équipe
de l’association de sauvegarde
des hortillonnages.
Là-bas, au bout du quai, il y a Michel,
qui rajuste son bob.
Il me regarde, un peu méfiant.
À l’époque, j’avais les cheveux
un peu plus longs qu’aujourd’hui.
« Toi, là, longue chevelure,
dans mon bateau ! »
Je m'exécute.
« - Tu sais conduire ?
- Je sais pas, mais je peux apprendre. »
Deux, trois manœuvres
et je prends le commandement du bateau.
« Bon. Tu vois, là-bas, le grand saule ?
- Oui.
- Tourne à gauche. »
À gauche.
« Là-bas. Regarde,
Tu vois ce champ avec les salades ?
Ça, c’est le champ de René et Thérèse.
Après le champ, à droite. »
Je tourne à droite.
« Hé ! Regarde
le martin-pêcheur, tu l’as vu ?
Tu l’as vu ?
Eh bien, regarde, suis-le.
Encore à gauche là-bas. »
Un coup à gauche, un coup à droite.
Évidemment, comme tout le monde,
je me retrouve perdu.
Un peu hors du temps.
Puis on arrive dans une espèce
de grand truc, ça s’élargit :
l’étang de Clermont, la plus grande
tourbière des hortillonnages.
C'est à peu près dix hectares de tourbière
creusée à la main de l'homme.
C’est un petit matin d’automne,
il y a une brume, le soleil qui est là,
d’un seul coup, paf, la brume se lève,
le soleil apparaît et alors là, extase !
Instant magique.
Je me rappelle de deux choses
à ce moment-là.
La première, c’est le sentiment
« Je suis ici chez moi ».
Et la deuxième chose, c’est :
« Mais comment je ne suis
jamais venu ici avant ?
Comment se fait-il que je découvre
ça uniquement maintenant ? »
Là, on est 30 ans plus tard.
Je suis responsable d’un jardin paysager
d’un peu plus de 3 hectares
dans les hortillonnages.
J’ai une solide équipe d’animateurs
qui accueillent à peu près -
on espère autour de 5 à 7000
personnes, beaucoup d’enfants -
pour montrer une agriculture
respectueuse de l’environnement.
On fait de l'écotourisme.
On structure une équipe
d’intervention pour faire les berges,
pour répondre aux sollicitations
des propriétaires du marais.
Parallèlement à ça, je milite
dans le mouvement « Terre de liens ».
On a installé à peu près 250 fermes
de production biologique en France,
à proximité des villes,
pour sortir du bon légume,
pas très loin de là où il est mangé.
Depuis quelques années, ma vie,
elle s’est un peu accélérée.
J’ai découvert les voyages
et j’ai [décidé] d’emmener
un petit bout de mon pays avec moi
à chaque fois que je bouge.
Elle m’a permis de mettre
quelques gouttes de sueur
dans les Pouilles, en Italie,
il n’y a pas longtemps.
dans les montagnes de l’Atlas, au Maroc,
à Beyrouth, il n’y a pas longtemps,
à Jérusalem aussi.
C’est où le prochain jardin ?
J’attends avec impatience.
Je vais profiter un peu de cet instant.
Je voudrais vous emmener
là-dedans, en fait.
Mes parents, ils me l’avaient
bien vendue, la grande ville.
Ils avaient juste oublié un truc - normal,
on venait tous de la campagne,
donc on ne le savait pas.
C’est que des graines, comme j’ai là,
Il y en avait plein aussi
des belles, dans la ville.
Il y en a plein, plein, plein, plein.
Là, je les vois, il y en a plein ici.
J’en connais quelques-unes.
Je ne sais pas, toi peut-être -
Je vais reprendre un peu.
Quand je me pose ces questions-là,
je me dis que
si on m’avait dit jusqu’où ça irait,
cette aventure,
peut-être n’aurais-je pas fait un pas.
Je n’aurais peut-être pas osé démarrer.
La synthèse de ça,
c’est que ce ne sont que,
les unes derrière les autres,
des toutes petites actions.
Tout a été simple,
tout a été source de joie,
un peu de sueur et un peu de difficulté.
Alors peut-être qu’ici,
toi là-bas, infirmière,
peut-être seras-tu un jour à la tête d’une
maison de retraite d’un nouveau genre
où on s’occupe peut-être
un petit peu mieux des gens.
Peut-être qu’ici, il y a un architecte
qui va, par ses constructions,
nous fabriquer une nouvelle
manière de vivre ensemble.
Peut-être que là,
il y a quelqu’un qui ne sait pas
du tout ce que c’est sa graine.
Je te promets que, vas-y, mets-la dans la
terre, ça risque d’être merveilleux aussi.
Tout à l’heure, je vous disais que,
dans les hortillonnages, la tourbière,
j’avais ressenti le sentiment de
« Comment ça se fait que je n’ai pas
découvert cet endroit avant ? »
Je pense que je le sais, en fait.
Ce n’était juste pas le moment.
Et là, par contre, en ce moment,
là, maintenant,
j’ai l’impression que pour moi,
peut-être pour toi, peut-être pour...
peut-être pour nous tous
et maybe for you,
it is time.
(Applaudissements)